Scott how are you this morning Dan I'm
great man how are you
I'm spectacular what do you remember
about that night a year ago I remember
being being nervous and I don't get
nervous about television because as you
know it's just television and once you
demystify it and once you realize that
really nothing bad can happen even if
you do something truly awful it's still
just television but I felt nervous just
because I didn't know what it would feel
like right you're sitting out there and
the middle of this set by yourself and
you're off on this new endeavor and who
the hell knows what it's going to be and
I remember I remember having you come in
and I remember what it meant to me then
and what it means to me now the fact
that you'd come back I didn't take it as
any as a passing of any torch I felt
like it was more significant than that
because as I said that night and as I'll
say again you were one half of the best
team that ever did it and it felt like
you're present whether you put it this
way or not I decided to internalize it
is something of a blessing and that that
your blessing as we tried to do
something new I remember it felt it felt
very very important and and still does
that that you did that so whether
whether you meant that at all it didn't
it makes no difference because I I it
was my placebo it meant that it meant
that you were giving me a metaphorical
pat on the back and saying go get him
were you concerned or was anybody
concern of what I would say no no no
because what because honestly what what
could you say that was going to that was
going to you know blow the blow the
mothership up like if that was if there
was a Trojan horse moment if that was
the goal well we were also we were
taping and we just never would have run
it but no I wouldn't have neutered what
you had to say cuz I didn't I didn't
presume that there was anything that was
going to be that that you know
inflammatory or oh no he said this thing
about that guy
no and I liked the fact that you stood
up for me when I said I'm gonna wear the
visitors tag and everybody was trying to
get me to take my visitors tag off and
you go no let him wear it I went yeah
I'm gonna wear it I'm a visitor here I
don't want anybody to run into anything
you know someone stole that what well
the tech we had yeah we had the sticker
on the Mickey Mouse the statue that you
gave me the statue remains someone
someone took the thicker as a memento
Wow well get Pauli get the i-team on
that hello find out where my visitors
sticker is that I left there do you
remember your frozen Sports Center since
sports inter debuted 37 years ago today
vaguely vaguely and I remember I
remember doing a show on news which was
obviously not SportsCenter it but and it
was with Bill Pete oh and I remember not
having the vaguest idea that the show on
news was something of a wheel where you
get to the end of it then you started it
over again and I had a script everywhere
on the desk and Bill pitot as only bill
could deliver it he looked around to no
one in particular and said out loud we
have a script management Friday and in
in the break in between Sadie Epps all
right because the segments are lettered
and the bricks between the s and
repeating the A's some somehow we
managed to kind of cobble the scripts
back together so that we could try to
try to do it again but that that was
that was just a horrifying moment and I
believe that the first time I was out
there in the big room it was it was
Linda Cohen and I and I can remember
like you look back on it now and I I'm
sure I was trying so hard to say the
clever thing and to figure out the you
know what's going to be my thing I lean
on my little way to say homerun or
whatever and then you as you become more
comfortable with a setting you realize
that just let it you know let it come to
you just it doesn't have to you don't
have to be out there trying to be Shecky
Greene at the Catskills or something
yeah I think everybody got caught up in
that for a while that they thought they
could be successful as a sports center
anchor if you had a catchphrase and I
went no no no that that that's not if
you can write and you look comfortable
and you look halfway decent you can do
this if you have knowledge the catch
phrases that's just something silly that
you
we started it and then we realized that
it became sort of our stick and then
Oberman and I tried to discredit our
stick by then making fun of our
catchphrases with some of the stupidest
things you could possibly say on TV and
even those caught on so then you
realized oh we're in so deep we're never
going to get out of this catchphrase
he'll blubber it's a clever thing to do
to create the create your own cottage
industry then make fun of it and you're
then you're profiting from both sides of
it of it and and but you're right about
the comfort and that's the that's the
most doing what we do and that's that's
a dirty little secret about our business
is that it isn't particularly difficult
to do it there are lots and lots of
people who do radio and TV all across
the country it's very difficult to do it
well and to do a well and make it look
easy and that only comes if you feel
comfortable in your surroundings if
you're not afraid to stumble a bit in'
and fall and to just let yourself be
yourself and once you reach that place
well then you're you're either going to
succeed you're going to fail based on
who you are you're not not some not some
role you're trying to be not some person
that you're going out there and
pretending you are for the hour and and
fortunately and thankfully with this new
endeavor it it felt like a comfortable
place almost immediately and that that
was frankly kind of surprising because I
just you know I didn't know I didn't
know if it would feel that way or if it
would feel like some some odd danced I
was trying to learn though just was
offbeat or something Scott Van Pelt
joining us Dan Patrick show can we have
full disclosure here that I tried to
entice you to join us at NBC sure how
close were you to leaving and joining
joining us at NBC at the time that that
and if I can I don't want to sell I
don't want to say too much but I mean I
think people can probably connect the
dots that if I was going to go there
what was I going to do and there was
discussion about something that perhaps
would have looked a bit like this
a show that was mine to fill out the way
that I wanted to fill it out with
whatever I wanted to do and that was at
the time I just I don't I wasn't
mentally ready to do it when some
when they say oh you you want to do a
show and you say okay well what is it
they say oh well whatever you want to do
you think well I don't know what I don't
know what I wanted to be you tell me
what I wanted to be right and I guess
having having had the chance to do a few
more years of radio or you become more
comfortable with the sound of your own
voice sharing what you really think
about things and realizing all right I
could do that in a TV space I guess the
the what I'm saying is is that the the
people that I talk to were all fantastic
and be the offers were were intriguing
it they just they were more they
frightened me I think more than I was
able to to confront you know I just
couldn't I couldn't imagine trying it
then and then this this chance to do
this show here happened several years
later while I was just a little more
confident with the idea that I'll take
that step off the edge so you know the
contracts up in a few years the going
rate apparently I see is escalated in
the time since we've last spoken if if
if we're thrown away those giant
Powerball money checks you know people
have my number sky I'm sure when you
talk again and you got to embrace debate
to get that kind of money though yeah
but you know do you do you Dan I so I'm
told so I'm told you got to embrace
debate there and yeah how much do you
like Tebow do you like Tebow an awful
lot I actually he's actually a guy that
I I know pretty well and I'm afraid I'm
too close to the situation to
objectively be able to debate his
relative merits as a baseball player and
or a football player or anything else
that you might Scott Scott Scott I
needed no lukewarm takes from Scott Van
Pelt oh yeah you got but I to get Scott
Scott from the Golf Channel it took me
how many how long did it take me to pry
you away from the Golf Channel to come
to the mothership it was yeah it was
about a year in the making and and even
then even then it was only because an
executive there screwed up his peon
comes to you with an offer this is your
chance to go from
oh-ee okay and then the Yankees come to
you and they say hey we'd like you to
come play for us well then it's it's the
onus is on the double a team to make the
offer better and the offer I was given
was actually less than the Yankees
offered and so I tried to explain to the
gentleman sitting across from me no no
at a minimum you have to just offer a
dollar more that that's sort of how it
works and it was a combination of you
prying and and them just absolutely it
was a three-putt from two feet damn
that's how that it was like hell up
I'll never forget this I was fitting it
an in-and-out in Las Vegas covering the
tour event there and it was just I had
in a pic I had an epiphany but some
called a moment of clarity and I said
you know what I'm going to the Motor
Show and you're a better man for it hey
congrats on the success of the show
midnight each night you can see Scott
following Sports Center or else his own
version of SportsCenter how did I do
that Redemption yeah all right
and he's Dan T's over promote and
under-deliver all day long if you miss
his show you'll die
how's that some have said yeah I
appreciate you Dan you know that man
thank you so much for every night Scotty
thanks for joining us and serve an pz
Scott Van Pelt the Dan Patrick show
weekday mornings on audience